good afternoon
everyone so i would like to
welcome you all to the second session
in the sbi 2 high content 2020
conference
i'm very excited about this session it
is on high content imaging innovations
we have two talks for you on
complementary technologies
my name is jeff moffitts i'll be one of
the moderators of this session which is
also co-moderated by david andrews
our first talk today is going to be
from dr sandro santagata sandro
is an associate professor at harvard
medical school and practices
neuropathology at brigham and women's
hospital
where he directs a a laboratory in the
department of pathology
he's also a member and a leading player
in the liquid
center at harvard in the harvard program
in therapeutic science
as well as the hms laboratory of systems
pharmacology
and he is playing major a major role
in generating cellular atlases
of tumors as a part of the national
cancer institute
moonshot human tumor atlas network
he has been a huge pioneer in the field
of high dimensional pathology so
massively multiplexed immunofluorescence
as a tool for understanding the
architecture of tissues
and how that architecture plays a
critical role in pathology
and i think it's just going to be such a
treat to have him here today
and have him tell us about this
technology that he
has been involved in the development of
and its
application so with that
can we go ahead and start up sandra's
talk
hi my name is sandra santagada i'm from
brigham and women's hospital and harvard
medical school
today i'll present a talk uh multiplex
imaging to understand the high
dimensional pathology of human cancer
my disclosures i'm a consultant for
raresight and we use
some of their slide scanners for imaging
part of the slides in this presentation
uh first i'd like to thank um members of
the lab of systems pharmacology
uh directed uh by peter sorger who are
the foundation and creative spirit
behind the multidisciplinary
tissue imaging and work that i will
present today a brief outline
i'll first give some context about
anatomic pathology
then i'll address some broad themes in
multiplex the tissue imaging
focusing on approaches as well as some
key areas of use in particular
immune profiling but also translational
research basic science
some cell biology and finally atlas
construction
this is the foundation of anatomic
pathology glass slides
h and e stained tissue sections immune
is the chemistry of one or two markers
per slide
then the use of a light microscope
interpreted by a pathologist
and then uh read out as a diagnosis i
will not
in this talk focus at all on ai
and hne and its role in diagnostics
which is a transformative
new uh field for pathology
instead i'll focus on multiplex tissue
imaging um
so our role in pathology is as disease
taxonomists
we are our goal is to classify tumors
and we
we do that basically on this concept of
histogenesis we're looking at the
similarities of tumor cells
um with the suspected cell of origin and
we do this based upon like microscopy
and some images of chemistry
and h e so basically we're phenotyping
tumors and putting them into categories
recently although not too long ago we
started integrating genetic
information into this diagnostic process
so the classification now includes
well-established
molecular genetic parameters as defining
features of tumors and there's an
integration
in our diagnosis that involves phenotype
and genotype
the more precise categories now these
more precise categories are the
foundation for genomically guided
clinical trials but what's next and can
we
extract more useful information from
these slides than we have been doing
already this is an example of our
pathology workflow just to give you a
broad sense that we provide different
information at different stages
in the operating room when the patient
is still on the operating table
we receive tissue fragments that we
freeze and perform tissue sectioning
and h e review usually the quality of
those tissues is not
extraordinary and the diagnosis can be
challenging
a few days later we have fixed tissue
in formal and fixed paraffin embedded
ffpe
that has much better morphology on h e
and also we can perform ihc
and at that point we provide a first
diagnosis
we then can alter and amend the
diagnosis
and add in additional information when
we receive genetic information from fish
or pcr
or methylation studies copy number
analysis targeted sequencing et cetera
et cetera
and at that point often two to three
weeks later we provide an integrated
diagnosis
but still as you can imagine a lot of
information is left
unextracted in these specimens so where
does multiplex
tissue imaging fit in in this paradigm
and i think the more we think about this
the more we think
everywhere understanding cell
composition cell states
and spatial arrangements clearly will
have roles in
in clinical use in patient diagnostics
in the development of drugs
for treating currently untreatable
diseases
as well as in pre-clinical development
and i will argue even further
uh maybe one of the more exciting areas
indeed will be in basic science
discovery using human tissues for
for basic science and cell biology
so this is pretty much a
transformational moment for pathology
where
we're going um from flatland a
two-dimensional world of h e
and ihc into uh space land
a higher dimensional world where we're
extracting features that we have not
been able to do
uh yet to date with the technologies
that we've had in hand
so this is really a moment that i think
will
will bring us dramatically into the
future as a field
and the assays that are poised to do
that are are these multiplex antibody
based imaging tools
where we image 20 to 60 antibodies all
on a single slide
and by doing that we can we derive a
tremendous amount of information high
content information
that allows us to define cell types
their states and their spatial
arrangement ships
so now we can identify this as a
fibroblast and the proximity to a
lymphocyte and where the tumor cells are
and how far they are from blood vessels
etc etc later on dna damage
proliferation
and other phenotypic markers so it's
really an amazing
um new ability that we have and in doing
so what we hope to you know
the aspiration here is to find tissue
motifs and spatial networks of cells
and to use that information for patient
stratification
drug target discovery and efficacy as
well as precision medicine so this is
where the field is moving rapidly
towards
at the moment i won't go into a lot of
detail
uh in terms of the two of the methods
that are used but their optical imaging
methods
and their ablation imaging methods these
i generally use antibodies that are
conjugated either directly or indirectly
to fluorophores and then
then information about fluorophore
signal is captured by a
by by a microscope and then there are
other methods that use uh
antibodies that are conjugated to metals
and use later laser ablation or ion beam
sputtering
and those are the two main methods i
think the key point in this though
is that there that no method is the
perfect method uh there are benefits and
limitations to each
and considerations need to be made in
terms of resolution sensitivity
dynamic range the maximum number of
channels the speed of acquisition
the complexity of the data and the
method the cost
and whether uh you need whole slide
imaging or region of interest analysis
uniformly though there's clearly an
underestimation of computational
analysis required to understand this
data
the data management and and how you need
different people
with different expertise to work
together as a multi-disciplinary team
for integrated uh for developing
integrated insights
the method that we use is called tissue
cyclic immunofluorescence it was
developed at the lab of systems
pharmacology at harvard medical school
by jerry lynn
and peter sorger in brief it's an
antibody based method in which the
antibodies are directly conjugated to
fluorophores
generally three antibodies um those
antibodies are incubated with
ffpe tissue there's a nuclear stain four
channel imaging of the three antibodies
and a nuclear stain
then photobleaching and successive
cycles anywhere from eight to 20
of this of this type of imaging is
performed
the data is registered and then stitched
together
to create these 20 plex images and then
that data
is used for image segmentation and
subsequent analysis
i'll just give you two examples just to
give you a sense of the imaging you can
see that there are grids here so these
are each individual fields of view that
are stitched together this is from a
tonsil
and this is of a lung cancer so we
generate these large gigapixel images of
resection specimens that are up to five
centimeters in size
square centimeters in size and then we
construct
by stitching together these many views
these
these
complex these complex data sets
and you can just track each of the
channels through and see how how
the different markers are present and
their spatial distribution
critically it's important to use
antibodies
of high quality and we publish methods
for qualifying antibodies in high
dimensional space one of the ones that
is most powerful is to use
multiple antibodies three four or five
to the same target
and then to look on a pixel by pixel
level of how the
how this the signal uh correlates
between the different antibodies so you
can find good antibodies with high
correlation
as well as antibodies that are that are
not well correlated at all
their cell level analysis to make sure
that the antibodies are co-segregating
uh the markers are co-segregating with
other expected markers then tissue level
analyses that the markers are expressed
where they're supposed to be expressed
and further uh methods that we describe
in in in the manuscript
but um this is helpful for both
well-established as well as for new
antibodies
and particularly for new antibodies
where patterns of staining are not
necessarily obvious the key areas of
focus of multiplex imaging
in clinical care and and cancer research
generally have been you know it's been
driven mostly by immune profiling so
i'll focus quite a bit on that
in the area of patient management but
also for clinical trial correlative
analyses trying to find biomarkers of
response
trying to find new biomarkers uh for
first for initiating
new types of immune therapy trials but
also thinking beyond
immune therapy i'll give some examples
of that as well as
in pre-clinical research in basic
science and as i mentioned atlas
construction too
it's often nice to have research tools
and analytical approaches
that are that work in the research space
but also
can be applied directly to the clinical
space allowing for a rapid transition of
ideas into clinical practice
one example is shown here this is the
current the current state of the art for
immune profiling in the clinic where
six markers are generally used to to
profile a tumor this is an exophytic
large melanoma with an attacks piece of
skin with melanoma in situ which i'll
show in the next slide
typically now one one channel is used
for dna staining the other for a tumor
marker
and then leaving only four markers
available for uh
profiling the immune cells in that
tissue this is a
an image of only uh five marker five
images of a
40 uh plex data set
um and you can already imagine that by
going from from 6 to 40 it provides
a tremendous amount of capacity for for
detailed cell composition analysis um
and and here i show some umaps uh you
know
demonstrating t cell and immune
checkpoint marker
um distribution i'm not showing the
markers here for macrophages or
dendritic cells or nk
cells uh etc etc so you can
see that we would the state of the art
soon will be a much deeper
compositional analysis and spatial
analysis of tissues
you can also get a sense of how
important it is to do whole slide
imaging so instead of small fields of
view
assessing the entire tumor and the
neighboring region
will provo in principle provide
important information and we need to
start to explore whether that's true or
not
in the months ahead spatial analysis is
also very important
uh here um as i was mentioning there's a
there was a region of melanoma in situ
in that prior
image here's that region of melanoma in
situ these in the melanocytes trickling
along here
in red that the neoplastic melanocytes
here is a region of tumor regression
where the immune system the cd
uh eight positive cd3 positive t cells
here here seen in white are are um
are involved in in the
death of those cells and then here is a
region where that's where it's fully
resolved with no melanocytes are left
so there there's a need for regional
analysis here you can see there are lots
of t
cells here there are many macrophages
there's need for cell cell interaction
analysis
as you can start to appreciate here at
higher power
and in fact more so uh we're learning
that there's actually quite a bit of
subcellular information
that can be extracted here is a tumor
cell um
a melanoma cell and here is
a is a lymphocyte this is a lymphocyte
that is a
t cell exhausted so it has both lag 3
and tim 3 expression
but the expression is not uniform it's
actually polarized which is also quite
interesting and the meaning of this type
of information
uh is is is again another area of
of intense focus i'll show you some
applications now for clinical trial
correlatives this is work from
nina farquilla that she performed while
at the lsp
she was interested in in understanding
responses to
um naraparib a parp inhibitor and uh
pembro
elizumab uh targeting pd1 in ovarian
cancer in the tapacho trial
so she she analyzed using multiplex
imaging and genomic approaches
samples from 62 patients and in doing so
she was able to find determinants of
response
and those broke down into two types
there was there were there was the
determinant
that was dictated by mutational
signatures that showed a homologous
recombination deficiency in the tumor
cells
signature 3 as it's called and there was
also a spatial component too there was a
determinant and that was finding
interferon primed exhausted cda t cells
in proximity to pdl-1 expressing
macrophages and tumor cells in the
microenvironment
patients that had either one or both
responded to treatment
patients that had neither did not
respond
but again um i think there are much
deeper analyses are possible
here is an image a high resolution image
image from one of the samples
and you can see that um there this is
really
quite impressive how macrophages have
polarization
of their pdl1 in the process of
neutralizing and leading to dysfunction
of t cells
so a lot of sub-cellular information is
still present in these samples and a lot
more
analysis is required of this of this
deep
high content information and here's
another image
that is even more striking in some
regards where where it's
it's optical sectioning of five micron
sections these are 250 nanometer
sections that have been stitched
together and
we're focusing in here on pdl one in
green and pd1
in purple and you can see almost a
structural biology type
assessment and view here of the
interactions between
these two molecules and their potential
juxta signaling
so again more and more information is
available that we can start to extract
from tissues than we've ever been able
to extract
before another application in the
immune profiling is is this example from
jennifer guerrero who also
works as part of the lsp and is at
brigham and women's hospital and
dana-farber cancer institute
she's interested in studying triple
negative breast cancer and has shown
that in tnbcs that are brca
mutant uh there's a large number of
of uh of macrophages seen here in in
in light blue and that there's also a
large number of
dysfunctional t cells shown here in
green
compared to normal triple negative
breast cancer so using high dimensional
single
cell profiling of human tnbc she's been
able to demonstrate a significant
increase in tumor
associated macrophages as well as
dysfunctional t cells and brach immune
breast cancer and now she too
is is gearing up to analyze tapacho
samples in this case
the the triple negative breast cancer
arm of tapacho
studying parp and pd-1 inhibition in
in over 50 tnbcs
we're using immune profiling in somewhat
different ways as well we're trying to
find new targets
for instance hearing glioblastoma in
work by shannon coy one of our fellows
we're studying pure allergic signaling
by the cd39 cd73 pathway that takes atp
and breaks that breaks it down into
adenosine which is immunosuppressive to
t
cells we've shown that glioblastoma
tumor cells express high levels of cd73
a good subset maybe one third of them do
there's also
um presence of the presence of cd39 the
upstream
enzyme in the process that's found in
macrophages dysfunctional t
cells as well as in endothelial cells so
a complex immune
environment is being created by this
multi-component enzyme system in
glioblastoma
where you studied this the expression of
40 markers in
in about approximately 200 samples and
now we have single cell analysis
and ecosystem analysis underway to
understand how these
cells and and these enzymes come
together to create an immunosuppressive
environment
and hopefully we'll be able to now take
this this assay forward in a prospective
data collection
studying anti-cd73 agents in in
a bayesian adaptive clinical trial but
what about beyond immune markers and and
what does that look like and here's a
couple of just
sort of brief examples in that exophytic
melanoma from before if you just look at
the tumor compartment that's lit up here
in multi-colors
what we find when we use a number of
different markers is that we have
different types of immune of
tumor phenotypes here in roi 2 and 4
we have we have tumor cells that are
proliferative they express ki-67 and
pcna
and they're also differentiated they
express melanoma markers mitf
however in regions one and three we
don't have those markers these areas are
more differentiated and they're slowly
they're slow proliferations not fast
proliferators and these have been
postulated as being resistant states to
therapy
so there are these dynamic oscillations
and restructuring of cell states that
occur in tumors even across a few
centimeters of tissue that are important
to understand
and we want to understand the drivers of
these state transitions and the clinical
implications for
for cancer care we see this in a whole
range of other cancers including colon
cancer and
others as well and beyond uh those more
sophisticated high dimensional
phenotypes
you know in in in cancer biology we
often uh into clinical work we often
will characterize
uh the proliferative the proliferative
state of tumors and we do that in two
ways either by looking at ki-67 which is
a
a marker of proliferation whether tumors
are low medium or high proliferators
or by mitosis simply counting the number
of mitosis that are present
in a in a in a defined number of high
power fields
this can be complicated though because
in a single in in a single
wrist stratification system um in a
tumor that might be let's say six
centimeters
uh having four mitosis and 50
high-powered fields
um indicates that that's a low risk of
recurrence where as having just two more
six and fifty high power fields and the
same size tumor
indicates a much higher risk of
recurrence so these are complicated
assessments that that are now currently
done by by visual review
and maybe there's more information that
we can start to bring by using more
sophisticated
multiple marker techniques that are
based on multiplexing
and uh and and and quantification
and i just want to show you just sort of
a glimpse into that by work from george
ogalla and sherbrooke
in our group at the lsp uh studying
different proliferative markers
and what you can see here is uh it's
clear that the traditional marker ks67
is not sufficient
alone to define cell proliferation in
fact we find cells that are often ki-67
negative that have other proliferation
markers such as pcna
a dna replication factor and mcm2
uh replication licensing factor so by
using a multivariate
um marker of proliferation which we call
them the mpi
the multivariate proliferation index we
can define proliferation in
more sophisticated ways using multiple
markers so mpi1 cells are proliferative
these cells here are mpi0 quiescent and
these cells are arrested by expressing
one
or sometimes both cell cycle arrest
markers
we can then you know we can then look at
a tumor this is a breast cancer look at
two million cells in a cancer
separate the immune cells and the
stromal cells from the tumor cells focus
our analysis in on the tumor compartment
identify the cells that are
proliferative not just the ones that are
ks67 positive but the other ones that
are ks67 negative but are likely also
proliferative
and then start to understand their their
their what the meaning of of these
complicated more well more uh more
uh more comprehensive uh indices
in in understanding proliferation here
showing that these indices are higher
uh proliferative cells are higher in
triple negative breast cancer in her2
and also studying their the spatial
distribution of these states
across breast cancer lung cancer and
ovarian cancer
it gets even more sophisticated and
interesting when you start to consider
cell cycle
markers and here just just to give you a
sense of what
that starts to look like and it's we're
clearly going to need conceptual and
algorithmic innovations
to start to make high dimensional
assessments and apply
metrics to clinical trial samples and
and hopefully that's not in the too
distant future
i just want to give you another example
of cell biology discovery from
again from dirt work by george oglia my
group works on stress responses in
cancer we study heat shock factor one
which is the transcription factor
that when cells are stressed it it
trimmerizes
uh translocates the nucleus and and
turns on um
proteins the protective proteins uh
called chaperones
so this is how cells survive a whole
range of different types of
perturbations
and we found in in work that i won't
discuss that hsf1 is co-opted in cancer
cells placed in a nucleus and helps
provide cancer cells with a whole range
of functions
that permit malignant progression and
malignant
behavior and in georgia decided to use
both multiplex tissue imaging
and and then going back and forth
between those images
and live cell imaging to try to
understand um the biology of hsf1 in
cancer
and what we found was kind of
interesting so hsf1 is diffusely present
in the nucleus
of of cells before stress and now this
um these are this is cell culture so
acid1 is present in nucleus
when you stress cells with either
thermal stress or hsp90 inhibition or
proteomic
inhibitors what's interesting is that
actually it goes into these foci
and um decades worth of studies have
shown
or have indicated that cells that have
foci are stressed and therefore will
have high chaperones and that work has
been based upon bulk analyses
of of rna and protein western blots and
rna pcr type work as well
but single cell analyses have not been
performed and if you look at these
videos it's kind of interesting because
after stress foci form and then some
some cells will resolve
um the foci and other cells will not
resolve the fosa and go on to die
and this is kind of a bit of a spoiler
as to the punch line of the of the story
previously using ihc we only found hsf1
um you know present in the nucleus but
we didn't see any any foci
presumably because of the resolution
limitations of of ihc
but when we use the amino fluorescence
um here in a colon cancer you can see
very clearly that hsf1
is present in foci and in fact in fact
it's present in foci
mostly in tumor cells but not in stromal
cells so we were finally able to detect
these foci in bonafide human tissues the
kind of stuff that we were seeing
previously in cell lines
and this is a just a zoomed out view of
a colon cancer
and that these foci are present in these
many spatial arrangements
uh across the tumor epithelium we found
that h614 preferences
located in cancer cells as i mentioned
in primary tumors but we also found that
they were
inversely correlated with chaperone
expression exactly the opposite of what
we expected from
from bulk analysis of cell culture so
you can see that
that here is um decreasing chaperones
with increasing levels of
hsf1 foci so so that was a bit
perplexing and georgia then turned back
to
cell culture to study that more and
found indeed
when cells have foci they have very
little
chaperone rna expression and when they
don't have foci they have very high
chaperone expression and here is a plot
showing that inverse correlation
and then if we were to track these cells
over time what we found
is that the cells that do not resolve
their foci when they form
go on to die under under apoptotic
mechanisms
where cells that form foci but then
resolve these folks that go on to live
presumably because these are the ones
that are releasing
releasing hsf1 to uh transcriptively
activate chaperone expression
and we with biophysical studies and i
won't go into much detail on them
we we we do see that hsf1 forms small
foci
these then coalesce to form larger and
larger aggregates the
number of fossil goes up rapidly and
then decreases as these
smaller foci coalesce into larger
volumes they become granular
and the model that we developed using a
number of biophysical techniques is that
and
in these stages hsf1 is a liquid it's uh
that can then uh these photos that can
resolve and hsf1 can then go on to
tran transcribe target protective target
genes
whereas over time as the foci become
more and more solid
asus one is aggregated and and uh heat
shock or historic response
cannot be induced okay so that's an
example of cell biology
moving back and forth between tissues
and um
and cell lines to come up with with
hopefully new insights into regulation
of a pathway
that's been well studied before but not
studied in this manner
and now i just want to end um in the
last couple of minutes
discussing the building of atlases and
this is an effort that's ongoing now
as part of the human tumor atlas network
a network of 10 centers that are
building atlases of pre-cancers
and cancers to better understand um
tumor biology and and the complex tumor
landscapes that that are
that are that are you know parts of
these
of these tumors and i'm just showing
these early maps of the night sky and
the world
500 years ago and 500 years later we
have more sophisticated views
and i think we're just at the beginning
of a similar type of mapping and
cartography
this molecular and cellular cartography
that hopefully in the future we lay the
foundation for
really important advances for the future
of cancer biology
this effort is really really tremendous
in many ways and one is that it's a
motivator of technology and software
development
this is one example where we're taking
one specimen doing serial sections
distributing those sections across
across the country to multiple centers
that are then running
different assays on these um
on on these same specimens so that we
can do uh
we can do cross-platform comparisons uh
some of those assays are size if
others are codecs and maybe and
multiplex ihc
rna spatial profiling using
glmx also histology and obviously high
dimensional analyses
so this this effort is underway this is
an example of
seisif data on a colon cancer from that
effort
you can see here 25 different sections
have had
seisif these are two by two pieces of
colon cancer
and now we're building three-dimensional
reconstructions of these tumors
and uh and doing comparisons between
multiple assays these are large data
sets
2.5 terabytes of data just in this one
colorectal cancer
and an analysis of 10 million cells
we're learning some very basic truths
that ffpe
has great morphology and frozen sections
often do not
a lot of tissues and tissue banks are
have
ice crystal artifacts so methods that
require frozen tissues are
are going to need some significant
methodological
biospecimen work to improve the quality
of these types of specimens
we're also learning that there are
issues with public viewing how do you
how do you make complex tissue images
intelligible and shareable
and we've we're trying to do this with a
software developed by peter's group at
the lsp
called minerva this is our current
practice where we teach each other at
the microscope using multi-headed
microscopes
uh in the in the high dimensional world
we're hoping to be inspired by
by um by work done in museums with
digital docents and
interpretive narrative narration so for
instance we've developed a narrator
where you can upload images generate
stories
uh different types of stories either
histology based stories or data analysis
stories
their table of contents content so you
can click through and go to the
different
the different waypoints and at each each
way along the line
the viewer can disengage with the story
and pan pan and zoom
look for themselves uh their channel
groupings that are offered to show
certain features but they're also
individual channels that can be explored
separately the software for minerva is
available
on our github and also we have some
stories available on our seisif.org
website
and offer a whole range of training in
terms of the basics of using this tool
which is now described on a bio archive
manuscript that's currently under
under review as well i also want to
point out that
that the group is working very hard on
image processing pipelines this is
worked by artem sokolov and dennis
shapiro
using developing a pipeline called
mcmicro and
hopefully you'll hear more about this
type of pipeline effort
in in the near future and its role in
the human tumor atlas network
so in closing i want to thank the lab of
systems pharmacology um
laura malizewski is the executive
director peter strzoger is the director
it's a fantastic multi-disciplinary
space that makes this kind of work
possible with software engineers data
scientists pathologists oncologists
etc etc just a fantastic place to work
and i feel very fortunate to be part of
the team
here are members of the team and with
that i'll just stop and
thank you all for for listening
you